E aí
[Música]
as teorias da conspiração ou será que
são verdades que só alguns nós tem
conhecimento
Esse é um tema que tem sido cada vez
mais falado neste tema das teorias da
conspiração embora elas remam tem já
aqui desde que a história digamos assim
recentemente e perder uma história para
começar a circular pela internet a
história de mostrar para poder pedir o
gato e das vacinas um pouco a dando a
entender que o Bill Gates teria
interesses próprios em criar um vírus
que depois levasse a a necessidade uma
vacina através da qual eu poderia
implementar um chip em todos nós E com
isso passar a ter uma espécie de
controle e provavelmente mais alguns um
grupo que conta o passaria a controlar
todos os as pessoas da terra através
desse chip bom Esta é uma de muitas
dívidas conspiração podemos encontrar
bom e se calhar algumas pessoas estarão
agora a pensar que se eu estou por aqui
esta história e a falar essa história
desta forma que atua duvidar dela e se
calhar Portanto o melhor é de começarem
já a duvidar do que eu venho dizer a
seguir é porque a estarei se calhar
feito com eles a outros estarão a
considerar a maioria certamente que a
história parece fazer pouco sentido e é
difícil cabimento Mas afinal o que é que
nos leva a acreditar em 3 dias ao
teorias da conspiração Pois é é comum
nos ligados às teorias da conspiração a
uma falta de confiança nas fontes
tradicionais informação por exemplo nas
autoridades públicas por outro lado elas
existem no fundo porque nós temos
necessidade de acreditar no que as
outras pessoas dizem o que é bom e isso
este chegar até aqui em termos
desenvolvimento humanos mas tem os as
suas falhas tem estes
o podem considerar a vá mais negativos
ainda o psicológico da Conspiração
envolvem crenças e envolvem a convicção
a convicção nessas mesmas crianças as
crianças que podem ser descritas como
representações apresentações que nós
fazemos do mundo que nos rodeia e que
são construídas com base nas nossas
experiências e conta convicção diz
respeito ao quanto é que nós acreditamos
nessas mesmas nessas mesmas crenças e
por vezes a aquilo que nós pensamos que
são teorias da conspiração até podem
mesmo não ser teorias da conspiração
neste sentido e serem mesmo fatos o que
vem complexificar é um bocadinho mais
tudo isto faz parte mais a nível
psicológico nós precisamos nós temos
esta necessidade de compreender o mundo
que nos rodeia de sentir controlados
alguma coisa do nosso o nosso mundo é e
quando não existe informação suficiente
quando não entendemos devidamente
a educação suficiente para algumas
coisas nós ainda tendemos mais a fazer o
preenchimento desse vazio com a
informação é algo até muito automático e
nós e é uma necessidade muito grande é
uma cidade também de segurança e esse
controle sobre o meio o controle sobre a
incerteza é que existe portanto
ambientes maiores certezas são mais
propícios desta situação e depois ainda
nós reforçamos temos a necessidade de
reforçar uma autoimagem positiva de nós
próprios ovos de grupos a que
pertencemos é e o que isso tem a ver bom
se nós sentimos que fazemos parte de um
núcleo muito restrito pessoas
conseguiram perceber algo que todos os
outros não perceberam isso também
reforça muito essa imagem é positiva são
vários aspectos que a nível psicológico
podem por dispor certa forma para esta
situação contexto de incerteza levam por
isso a
e as condições para usar uma antiga
conspiração porque nós ficamos mais
ansiosos ativamos mais os mecanismos
automáticos emocionais para a tomada de
decisão sobre as coisas e por isso
estamos mais sujeitos a certo
enviesamentos quanto mais a cidade ou
seja Quando pensamos sobre porque aqui
ao ser assim ou não como é que tentando
resolver nossa cabeça um problema pois é
é mais fácil utilizar estas pistas
histórias simples que preenche espaços
vazios que falta de informação e que nos
dão mais confiança é basta são muitas
vezes essas tais teorias da conspiração
e só nos Alguns de nós mais os ativos
acreditar nestas teorias do que noutras
a partir das todos nós podemos ir
acreditarem que inspiração alguma vez a
nossa vida que todos temos as nossas
crenças ir em tudo o que acreditamos é
mesmo provável mesmo foi ponto alto não
tem nada momento mas existem algumas
características ao modo de funcionamento
são mais facilmente
e é entre as pessoas que acreditam em te
ver com inspiração Pois é uma pessoas
tenho mais necessidade ter certezas
absolutas sobre as coisas que tenham
menos tenho o menor para virar
pensamento analítico que sofreu por
exemplo mais vezes do chamado
enviesamento ideológico ou seja de
acreditarem que tem que haver um certo
sentido para todas as coisas e alguma e
e ao que deu uma coerência a todo mundo
a mais individualismo também é outra
característica menor regulação emocional
da questão maiores dificuldades no
controle das nossas emoções e uma menor
interesse ou seja melhor compreensão
sobre a informação que recebemos e será
que se tivermos mais todos a mais
educação estamos menos subjetivas bom a
Pelos vistos fizemos uma criança que nos
identificarmos com algo ou alguém a com
uma mesma ideologia ainda é mais difícil
E se tivermos essa melhor formação e por
vezes com agravante utilizamos coisas
como as falácias da autoridade que
aquela coisa que nós dizemos que eu sei
muito bem o que é que estou a dizer
porque eu tenho muita experiência nisto
tenho um currículo muito grande nesta
matéria sou formado nisto e por isso é
muito bem o que estou a dizer e Por que
então este funciona assim porque esta
formação de crianças destas crianças só
as questões estão ligadas à construção
ou acredita acredita conspiração São
muito mais emocionais do que enviadas
pela razão e será que todos os que
espalham a estas crianças do fazem
inadvertidamente a maior parte das
pessoas acreditam nas teorias mas não
asformula não foram foram essas pessoas
que conceberam é abraça também tem
pessoas que utilizam estas falhas
digamos assim não fala com nós e o
abrimos nosso casamento para tentar
aproveitando isso passa
o vinagre informação por vezes em gente
vos conspiração outras coisas mas na
verdade é meu parte nós nem sequer tenta
encontrar explicações simplesmente ouvir
e disse mina informação que
automaticamente preencher aqueles
requisitos de preencher dar um
significado ao que está a acontecer a e
ainda mais quando nós vemos repetição
sucessiva determinado a história nós
passamos acreditar mais que ela é
verdade por um efeito de acessibilidade
Ou seja a um enviesamento de chamado
engajamento de disponibilidade a e tenta
a maior acesso a essa informação por
parte da nossa memória e portanto nós
tendemos a acreditar mais nela mais
ainda quando isto acontece em alguns
contextos e isso era uma questão agora
existem mais teorias da conspiração do
que alguma vez existiram eu não sei de
factos agora existem mais que eles me
conspiração alguma vez existiram Mas
elas têm formas de se disseminarem como
e antes porque agora é mais fácil
espalhar notícias falsas do que
verdadeiras é o que tu já agora também
da mastigação psicológica mas é E por
que é mais fácil porque teve por exemplo
redes sociais que rapidamente permitem
que as informações para a internet
acelera o processo de inspiração e
queria condições ótimas através de
certas redes sociais a criação de bolhas
bolhas que são digamos assim os nossos
amigos e um dos enviesamentos de
confirmação e disponibilidade se juntam
a e permitem ciliares e de confirmação
porque o que significa que nós estamos
numa rede a rede com pessoas com os pais
para temos muitas coisas em comum há
coisas em que acreditamos em comum
crianças a gostos e interesses e são
estas pessoas que onde está a circular
essa mesma informação que pode ser
repetido essa informação é repetida é
importante nós e é repetida e de acordo
com aquilo que provavelmente são as
nossas crenças Porque isto é um grupo de
pessoas de partida coisas
o conosco e ou seja nós tendemos a
confirmar é um é uma tendência que nós
temos a confirmar aquilo que já sabemos
e muito mais do que a infirmar logo
quando essa informação aparece numa
bolha da nossa confiança é este efeito
juntam é portanto um espaço propício a
confundir-se os patos ainda mais de
coisa opiniões ou com as verdades
alternativas que também é algo que
muitas pessoas que não diferenciam uma
coisa são fracos outra coisa são
opiniões e depois o problema de que hoje
em dia informação e muito mais
disponível a muito mais informação
disponível por imensos canais e
significa problemas na nossa capacidade
limitada no curso também essa informação
o que os leva cada vez mais quanto mais
informação vou tirar reforçar mais nós
tendemos a usar pistas apenas a ler só
algumas coisas a fazer leituras na
diagonal e isso ou é portanto uma
leitura mais intuitiva e logo com muito
mais facilidade sem diariamente e
conseguirmos nos prevenir será possível
aprender
e estas estas situações bom mais letras
ia mais desenvolvimento de pensamento
crítico não ter expectativas mudar a
forma como as pessoas pensam simples
simplesmente discutindo argumentos
online também será uma boa forma a
aumentarmos a consciência das
autoridades e instituições públicas
sempre simpáticos com aquilo que estão a
pensar com aquilo que as pessoas estão a
sentir informar explicar com mensagens
simples e diretas e repor e voltar a
repor sempre mas sempre os factos mas
sem fazermos uma oposição deliberada as
falsas narrativas que podem ter um Deck
Fire simplesmente por o fazer dessa
forma outro lá simplesmente o falso não
chega pois pode não ser suficiente para
alterar as memórias e a um psicólogo a
gasolina que desenvolve uma teoria
teoria da inoculação que está a ser
testada com alguns resultados
promissores que é precisamente nós
gerimos a percepção também como uma
vacina colocarmos no fundo desde o
início
é uma maior compreensão desenvolvemos
maior compreensão é para as crianças e
jovens como é que se desenvolvem Teoria
da Conspiração como é que envolvem
notícias falsas e com com isso concando
cada vez mais desde o início de saberem
como é que isto é feito são mais aptos
para as detectar é uma possibilidade a
estas teorias tem consequências
negativas negativas para a saúde
assistimos a classificação também não
acreditar nas vacinas por exemplo ou em
ou aí ou em conspirações a volta dessas
é um problema ou acreditar em português
as alterações é um problema é um
problema de saúde pública e é um exemplo
isso é tudo isto que eu disse parte será
isto mesmo com aquela hora acabei de
dizer a parte de uma teoria da
conspiração como forma de branquear as
pastilhas da Conspiração não isso é
Ciência e por isso sendo que conhecemos
hoje sobre o que pensamos sobre o que
definimos sobre inspecionamos sobre a
forma como nos com
e na verdade amanhã podemos descobrir
algo mais ou diferente e até o contrário
daquilo que agora estou aqui afirmar Mas
isso é é Ciência e é por isso que em
ciência estamos sempre a questionarmos e
a colocar em causa as teorias vigentes
as próprias teorias da própria ciência
mas com o método com fatos esperando a
evidência da causalidade ou da
correlação ou das experiências
singulares que cada um de nós pode ter
demonstrando transparente mente como é
que nós chegamos ao conhecimento que
temos e não com base simplesmente nas
nossas crenças e credos ou apenas em
intuições
o e estas ideias estas ideias que agora
aqui falamos O que são mesmo ideias que
valem a pena espalhar ao contrário das
teorias da conspiração obrigado a
E aí
[Música]